We're going to go through quite a lot of
material today and it's a bit of,
it will be reviewed,
but not very much.
Okay.
So we started with this fundamental
propositions here that you're viewing
the world through a narrative framework
and the narrative framework basically
lays out the world for you as a place in
which you can act.
And the reason that you act is to make
the state that you're in currently,
that that state that you're moving to
next better than the state you're in
now.
Now,
part of the reason that I had you write
about your past was because the early
cognitive scientists sort of took it for
granted that your model of where you are
now wasn't actually a model.
It was just reality.
Cause you look out in the world and you
can see the reality and there you are.
But that's not true because because
you're,
you're as constrained with regards to
the information that you have at hand
about the present just as much as you
are about the future or the past,
then you're,
your conceptualization of the present is
also a model.
Just like your conceptualization of the
future.
And the reason that's so important to
know is that if when you're moving from
point a to point b,
you make an error.
The error could be that you've predicted
the future or construed the future
inaccurately.
But it could also be that you've
construed the present or the past
inaccurately.
And what that means is that you didn't
start from where you thought you were
starting.
You know,
and,
and that happens for example,
that'll happen if you're moving forward
and you discovered that you have
weaknesses of one form or another that
you didn't know about when you made the
original plan.
And that what that means is that your,
your current conception of yourself is
sufficiently inaccurate so that you
can't move from that conception to the
future desired state without error.
And the other reason I'm telling you
that is because one of what that also
helps you understand is how broad the
domain of potential error is when
something you don't understand happens.
Because not only does it throw the
future that you're conceptualizing into
doubt,
it also throws the conceptualization of
you as a being in the present into
doubt.
And it's not obvious at all when you do
the initial search where in which of
those domains you're going to find the
error or where.
And so it's error is a more complex
problem than the,
than the cognitive scientists who are
interested in the comparitor models of,
of cybernetic processing had an had ever
conceptualized cause they thought they
kind of thought and behavior his terms,
which is while the world just presents
itself to you as it is,
so you're not going to be making any
errors of fundamental perception.
You just might be making areas of
prediction,
but that's far too optimistic.
Now we also know that this fundamental
narrative framework,
which gives you a sense of the value of
your current position and a destination
because you're a mom,
you're a moving creature,
you're an active living creature that's
interacting with the world and
transforming it all the time.
Um,
there's also,
there are also constraints on which the
narrative that you were going to
conceptualize an act out can exist and
the constraints are,
well they're piaget Yeti and constraints
in some sense.
Whatever it is that you're doing has to
support you while you're doing it.
That's constraint number one.
And that means that you're,
you're,
the path you take has to fulfill
whatever constitute the list of
necessities that you can't move forward
without.
And some of those we think of as basic
needs.
Like you have to breathe and you have to
eat and you have to have sufficient,
you have to have sufficient water and
you have to have shelter and all those
things.
And there's a,
you know,
the parameters within which those needs
can be fulfilled are pretty broad,
but you know,
so you can't think of it necessarily as
a simple problem or,
or that there are simple solutions but
they're still obvious constraints.
And not only do you have to fulfill all
those
fundamental obligations to yourself,
but you have to do it in a manner that's
relatively non contradictory so that
while you're pursuing one,
it doesn't decrease.
The chance that you're going to obtain
another and you have to do it in a way
that the way you do it now doesn't
compromise you doing it next week or
next month or next year.
That's where delay of gratification
comes in.
And then you also have to do it in a way
that fulfills your basic needs in a non
contradictory manner over different
spans of time and space while other
people are doing the same thing.
And so you think,
see that's a very,
very tight set of constraints.
And so the idea that that this narrative
could be anything is wrong because it
it,
it has to serve many masters
simultaneously.
And I'm not saying there aren't multiple
solutions to that,
just like there are multiple ways of
playing or winning a game,
but it's a constrained set of
possibilities.
So okay,
now the next proposition is that when
you're moving from point a to point b,
there's basically there's two or three
classes of things that can happen.
One is things that you don't want to
have happen and that obviously is
symbolically represented by the little
blue unhappy face.
And then there are positive things that
can happen and the positive things are
two fold in nature.
They have two fundamental elements and
behaviorists never tell you this.
So it's one of the fundamental flaws in
behavioral theory.
Things that indicate that you're moving
towards a desired goal are positive.
That's classic sophisticated behavioral
theory.
Those are incentive rewards because an
incentive reward indicates to you that a
consumer story reward is forthcoming and
there are different neuro biological
systems that underlie those two types of
reward.
Conservatory reward basically produces
satisfaction,
whereas incentive reward produces
excitement,
hope,
and movement forward.
And it's actually the kind of reward
that you liked better,
which is weird,
you know,
because you'd think that the most potent
reward would be consumed matory reward.
But people will work harder for
incentive reward,
then they will for consumer Tory reward.
And that's,
that's one of the things that makes
people very peculiar creatures.
And I think part of the reason for that
is that the incentive reward system is
part of the broader seeking system as
Jaak Panksepp describes it.
And so because the incentive reward
system not only tells you that a reward,
like an expected reward might be
forthcoming,
it also tells you that an unexpected
reward might be forthcoming.
And the reason that's so important is
because you actually view the world that
you don't understand partly through the
lens of threat because of something that
you don't understand happens.
It might be dangerous,
but also through the lens of
possibility.
Because if something you don't
understand happens,
that means there's an indeterminate
probability of reward.
And like these things turn out to be
extremely important.
So for example,
if you're in a long term sexual
relationship with a person,
the degree to which that relationship
might be sexually pleasurable will
decline.
And they're part of the reason for that
is that there's the novelty disappears
because novelty enhances incentive
reward.
And so one of the things that you can do
to maintain the romance in a
relationship is to mix some novelty.
And however you might be able to do
that.
And that usually involves playing in one
form or another in a certain amount of
creativity.
So it's not a trivial issue.
It's an important issue.
So anyways,
when when you're moving forward and you
encounter something that indicates that
you're going to achieve your goal,
the other thing that's happening at the
same time is that the fact that that
thing appears,
validates your entire perceptual scheme.
Right?
So a,
you're moving forward to the goal,
but b,
the whole plan that you're using to
construe the world in order so that you
can act so that you can move towards the
goal is also sufficiently.
Right.
And that's a big source of incentive
reward.
Not only your conception of the present,
but the whole framework itself.
Your conception of the present,
the future and your choice about what
behaviors to implement.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm imagining you're in a relationship
with young children or if your goal is
to be on a fulfilling relationship and
so to get from where you are to that
Subaru ordinance involves going through
some daily face might be faces.
So as you move towards your goal,
not always,
you're not always feeling,
oh no,
definitely not.
As you move towards a goal,
things you don't want and things you do
want might be happening and if something
you don't want happens,
then it depends on the,
it depends on the relationship of the
thing that didn't happen to your whole
goal hierarchy and the problem is,
and that's where we're going to go next
is when the unexpected thing happens.
Unless it's very simple,
which means that it can be modified here
and now with very little disruption,
then it has an incalculable effect on
the integrity of the entire plant and
that's that's why unexpected things in
particular are a class of their own.
Now it's complicated a because normally
when you're moving towards a goal,
if any obstacle appears,
it's unexpected obviously because partly
what you're trying to do when you lay
out a good plan is to make sure that the
pathway doesn't have any obstacles in
it,
so you almost never encounter,
just like you never encounter an
incentive reward without also
encountering a piece of evidence that
your plan is good.
You never encounter an obstacle without
also encountering evidence that your
plan is flawed.
And then the question is,
well,
how flawed?
And that's the big question.
And that's why there's a third category
of events that occur as you're laying
your plans,
as you're,
as you're laying your plans out in the
world and implementing them.
And that category is things you didn't
expect.
So not merely obstacles,
but there things you didn't expect.
So now that's what this diagram
basically indicates.
So as you're moving from the unbearable
present,
it's unbearable because you want to make
it better,
which is also something to think about
when you're considering why human beings
are constantly dissatisfied.
It's like,
well,
if you weren't vaguely dissatisfied with
the present,
you wouldn't be doing anything to try to
change it into the future.
And so there's a certain amount of vague
that dissatisfaction that's actually a
necessary motivator.
Now you know,
you hope that there are times when you
think things are good enough for right
now.
So you can take a break from constantly
walking up hill.
But you can also see that if you were
completely satisfied,
we know this from,
from animals like lions,
you know after a kill,
all the lions do is lay around until
they've digested all the food.
You know,
and they're probably satisfied.
But it isn't obviously the case that
that's the best possible.
So as you're moving from the unbearable
present to the desired future,
you can think that positive things
happen.
So those facilitate your movement
forward and negative things happen and
that interferes with your movement
forward.
Or you can think differently.
You can,
which is a slight reconceptualization
you can say that predicted things happen
and that unpredicted things happen.
So that's a,
that's a slightly different shift,
right?
Because when you talk about unexpected,
unexpected,
obviously you're not referring to
something that's only a manifestation in
the actual world.
It's also a relationship that you have
with the thing in the world.
Because expected means not only does it
happen,
but you knew it was going to happen.
Whereas unexpected means not only does
it happen,
but you didn't know.
So there's a subjective element and then
you could change that another way too.
Because,
and this is,
I think the most accurate way to think
about it,
which is it's not expected and
unexpected.
It's desired an undesired and there the
utility and making that transformation
is,
it brings motivation into the picture.
You're never only expecting or not
expecting,
you're wanting and not want.
Yup.
Huh?
Yes.
Sort of.
If you lay out a good plan,
you may say,
well,
here's 10 things that I don't want to
have happen that are relatively high
probability,
and then you could build a little sub
plan around each of those.
That constitutes a micro strategy within
the plant.
But the way to,
the way to conceptualize that
effectively is to think about this.
This isn't,
you don't have that plan ever.
You have a nested series of plants and
you're operating at one level of that
nested series out of time.
Now,
if the,
if the expected and if it's an expected
undesirable thing,
it usually affects a micro element of
the plan.
Right?
And so that you can change that and fix
it without too much effort.
If it's a macro element,
you know,
let's say,
uh,
okay,
you fail a course.
That's one thing.
Another thing is,
uh,
east European cyber criminals hijack
your hard drive and encode it and they
charge you $10,000
to decode it and then you don't have
enough money to go to university.
It's like,
okay,
well,
which of those events is more serious?
Well,
obviously failing the exam is not a
positive event.
It's a,
it's a somewhat unexpected event.
Likely if you were doing the work,
but it doesn't blow apart your entire
plan.
Whereas the,
the,
the theft of all your resources is a
macro failure.
Not only do you,
are you not getting from point a to
point B,
but the framework within which you're
conceptualizing point a and B is wrong,
but it might even be worse than that.
It's a super ordinate framework that
blows apart 10 or 11 different plants.
So it's that it's complicated because
things are never only predicted and an
unpredicted,
their desired and undesired and then
their desired and undesired to different
degrees.
And the degree depends on the place in
the hierarchy where the unexpected thing
is doing the disruption.
So,
but there's no way of getting towards
that level of description without
starting off as if you're only
implementing one plan at a time.
So this is,
this is an oversimplification that's
necessary before we develop a
sophisticated idea of,
of how it is that you're interacting
with the world.
Okay.
So a desired outcome,
that's an incentive reward.
It makes you hopeful and positive and
alert and energetic and willing to move
forward.
And it's what you want.
It's what you want.
It's a dopaminergic reaction
fundamentally.
Whereas if something that you happened
that happens that you don't want,
well that's both threatening technically
because you,
it indicates that a punishment is likely
and you don't necessarily know the
magnitude of the punishment.
And it's also punishing in and of
itself.
So those are,
that's obviously a category that you
don't want to have happen.
And the other problem is it's not easy
to bind it,
you know?
So look at it this way,
you have a relationship with someone and
it's kind of conflict laid,
you know,
and you think each time you have a
conflict,
do you think,
should I be in this relationship?
Well that's a big problem because you
actually don't know how much conflict
should you have before you shouldn't be
in a relationship.
And an answer to that is while you don't
know now there's actually some empirical
work on the topic so I can give you a
provisional answer,
which is quite interesting.
So there was a a research psychologist a
while back who I thought I did a
brilliant study and they had couples
record positive events.
Just qualitatively,
how many positive interactions did you
have with your partner during the day
versus how many negative interactions?
I don't think they quantified the degree
to which they were positive and
negative.
They're just going to assume that across
multiple instances that would wash out.
And what they found was it's quite cool.
They found that if you had fewer than
five positive interactions to every
negative interaction,
the relationship was going to collapse.
So now you can start counting and see if
that's appropriate to you.
But the other thing they found,
which I thought was really lovely,
was that if you had more than 11
positive interactions to one negative
interaction,
the relationship was also doomed.
And so you think you see,
you understand that,
right?
You'd,
everyone knows that because if someone's
wondering around treating you like a
goddess,
regardless,
the first thing you're going to do is be
just contemptuous of them and then
completely bored.
You want the person to harass you a bit
just so that you learn something.
That's part of it.
So,
but so it's also evidence that there's
actually someone there that you're
interacting with,
you know,
because if someone just does everything
you want all the time,
well,
I mean that might sound like an ideal
fantasy,
but you know perfectly well that if that
ever happened,
that's just,
you're just going to get completely
tired of that instantly.
Plus there's no,
there's no life in the relationship.
Right.
Which is a big issue.
So yes,
there's also people who are too afraid
to pick a fight with one another.
Right?
Right.
Arguably worse.
Well,
exactly.
the other thing too is you can be sure
that didn't have a relationship where
there's no conflict.
Nothing is being decided because thought
is conflict.
Even if you do it by yourself,
you know.
And so if,
if there are two of you in a boat and
you're trying to decide where you're
going in the future,
it started like that self evident.
There has to be some,
you have to have an opinion and your
partner has to have an opinion and
there's no reason at all to assume that
those opinions either will be or should
be the same.
And then you know,
you hope the relationship is solid
enough so that it can withstand the
tension of the conflict.
One of the things you've said about
marriage,
which I thought was because you can get
a very nice job of trying to understand
from a psychological perspective why in
the world you should bother being
married,
which is really a very interesting
question.
You know,
and one of the things,
one of the things he said was that you
don't need to tie two things together if
they'll just stay together of their own
accord.
So the fact that marriage is a,
your human universal,
which it is,
indicates that there is enough tension
within intimate relationships,
scent,
centrifical tension to blow them apart.
And some of that's just because people
are different and they clash.
But it's also because as you go through
life in a single boat,
you encounter huge waves and you know
you might get swamped.
So it's a big problem.
His point was that the marriage vow was
necessary because if you're a response
to,
okay,
potential conflict was I can leave,
you can't have the conflict.
Okay,
You know,
if,
if on the other hand you're with someone
and you think there's no bloody way I
can get rid of you,
no matter what I do short of murder,
I'm stuck with you for the next 30
years,
then we better work this out.
And so that makes the,
he thought of that as a container within
which a transformation could take place.
It was no chemical motif and that
without that pressure,
people weren't going to be sufficiently
motivated to really hash out problems.
And you know,
you can think of that,
think of that in whatever way you want.
But I thought it was an absolutely
brilliant observation.
Do you think that divorce is too readily
considered?
Well,
the problem is it doesn't solve the
problem.
It doesn't solve any problems usually
because for a variety of reasons.
One is it's probably you and not your
partner anyway,
or at least there's a 50 50 chance,
and if it's you,
you're just going to bring your
stupidity to the next relationship and
torture someone else to death,
you know?
So that's a big problem.
The next problem is,
is that if you can't work out the bugs
in this relationship,
why do you think you're going to be able
to do it in the next relationship?
Especially now that you're older and
more set in your ways.
The third is,
well,
you know,
what about the kids?
The fourth is,
I don't know if you've ever seen people
in a protracted custody battle,
but if you want to ruin your life,
that's a really good way of doing it
because that'll take you out for about
15 years and it'll cost you pretty much
all your money and it'll destroy your,
your closest relationships.
And I'll also make it virtually
impossible for you to be happy with the
next person that you're with because
they're going to be burdened by this
absolute catastrophe that's surrounding
you with regards to how you organize
your interrelationships with the people
that you love.
So,
so generally speaking,
I don't think that,
I don't think that it usually solves the
problem.
Now it's,
sometimes it does,
but my sense is it's probably introduced
more problems than it solved.
You know?
So I mean,
one of the things you might know for
example,
is that the only people who now get
married are people who are relatively
wealthy.
You know,
the fact that we've disrupted the
structure of marriage as an institution
since about 1965 say what that's meant.
What that has meant is that it's,
it's benefits are now only available to
people who are privileged.
So you can look up the stats yourself,
but if you're middle class and above,
the divorce rates haven't moved much
since the early seventies if you're
working class and below,
it's a complete catastrophe.
And what that's meant is that most ma,
many children who are in rougher socio
economic straights are being raised by a
single person who has absolutely and
100% overwhelmed by their multiple
commitments,
right?
Fulltime responsibility for children and
generally in employment in a
extraordinarily dismal,
low paying,
unstable and exploitative job.
So to me,
if you,
if you're like you guys are,
you're all going to be middle class or
above in all likelihood,
it's like,
it's fine for you.
It's not going to make a bloody bit of
difference,
all things considered.
But for people who are poor,
it's just been a catastrophe.
So,
okay.
So yes,
There
it's all sorts of reasons.
I mean,
first of all,
it's become socially acceptable,
right?
Divorce wasn't socially acceptable and
you can say,
well that's,
that was pretty hard on people who
wanted to get divorced.
It's like,
yeah,
obviously any rule is hard on people
that break it,
but that doesn't mean that there
shouldn't be rules,
you know,
now what rules there should be.
That's a whole different issue.
Um,
out of wedlock childbirth has become a
norm.
It was absolutely rare.
The 19 in the early 1960s vanishingly
rare and that's become,
it's,
it's acceptable.
Even though all the evidence suggests,
like if you actually look at the
evidence,
it's absolutely clear that kids who have
two parents do better than kids who have
one.
Now you know people,
when you tell people that,
they will tell you an anecdote about
someone they knew,
maybe their own parent who did a
wonderful job of raising them as a
single person.
It's like the anecdotes are irrelevant.
What's relevant is the bulk of the
evidence.
Of course,
there are situations where people are
better apart than together,
and of course there are situations where
one person can do a better job than to
people who were at each other's throats,
but it's,
it's aggregate.
It's aggregated examples that you use
when you're doing a scientific survey
and the results of those surveys are
crystal clear.
You know,
the other thing that's going to happen,
it's going to happen very soon,
is that there's going to be a very,
very,
very large number of elderly people who
are alone and be an elderly and alone
like no family.
That is not something you want to look
forward to,
especially when you start thinking that
you're going to be elderly for like 40
years.
So you know,
because say say it starts around 65 I
don't know how long you guys are going
to live,
but it's probably 95 is not an
unreasonable estimate and it might be
longer than that.
So because you know,
we're adding about three months to the
total lifespan every year,
right?
That's the rate of technological
improvement in relationship to overall
mortality.
So you know,
and that the degree to which we're
adding that extra lifespan is increasing
each year.
You know,
and it may hit get to the point where
we're increasing lifespan a year every
year.
Now.
I doubt it cause it'll probably,
it'll probably be an essay,
a Sim tote,
but it has been increasing for a very
long period of time.
So,
you know,
it's one thing to think about the
maximization of day to day freedom when
you're between say 15 and 40 45 after
that,
that's a whole different story.
And,
but modern people never think about the
last half of their life.
You know,
so why?
I don't know,
but maybe they're afraid to or
something.
But,
okay.
So here's the other way of looking at it
is when you're,
so there's lots of ways of
conceptualizing what you encountered
when you move into the world.
So we said,
well,
you know,
there's positive things you encounter,
negative things,
there's expected things and unexpected
things.
There's desired things and undesired
And another way of thinking about it,
which is more in some sense it's more a
empirical,
is that you encountered tools and
obstacles,
right?
And tools move you forward.
And tools are a funny thing because
they're sort of half objective and half
subject,
right?
There are thing,
but the thing is defined by their use.
But weirdly enough,
we tend to define thing by use.
You know,
and I mentioned this before,
so most people,
when they're thinking about language,
things that you use words to label
things,
but it seems much more likely that we
use categories as tools to act in the
world.
And so we don't see things,
we see the use of things or the fact
that they get in our way.
And so you're trying to set up the world
so that what surrounds you are entities
that you can use to get what you desire
and to eliminate obstacles.
And in fact,
that's what you generally do if you're a
good manager,
right?
A big part of being a good manager is to
first of all,
lay out a plan for people.
That's a hierarchy and and where the
hierarchical levels don't conflict.
And the second thing is you get rid of
obstacles for them so that they can come
to you and say,
well,
I can't do this because this isn't the
way your job is.
To get it out of the way so that they
can move forward.
So on.
It's a very good way of conceptualizing
yourself as a manager.
So now part of there's obstacles that
you understand and those would
correspond to the micro levels of the
hierarchy,
right?
And then there's obstacles that you
don't understand.
And when they come up,
they just blow apart your whole plant.
So now associated with that expected
unexpected,
desired undesired tool.
Obstacle is a corollary,
which is all the things that you're not
conceptualizing as tools or obstacles or
as things you don't know,
they're irrelevant.
And that's a really useful thing to know
because it means that whenever you're
looking at the world,
it's like the world has a sea of snakes
and you're only concentrating on one
snake at a time.
But then if you make a mistake dealing
with that single snake,
what happens is you're neck deep in
snakes because all of the things,
the thing is when you make a mistake,
and this is a critical issue,
when you make a mistake and you blow the
framework within which you're construing
the world,
the Framework that narrows it for you,
what happens is that all the things that
you've been ignoring become potentially
relevant.
And that's overwhelming.
And that's partly why your body reacts
as if it's under tremendous stress.
So for example,
you know how these things work.
And again,
I think betrayals,
the best example,
if you have a partner and they be trey,
you then all the things that you thought
were true about the mart and all those
things you ignored as irrelevant turned
out not to be irrelevant at all.
So you know,
maybe the person told on a twice weekly
basis that they were too busy studying
to spend any time with you.
And you know,
you just put that down into the
irrelevant zone after some coming to
terms with it.
And then you find out,
well that isn't what they were doing
during that time.
And then the next question is,
well,
what else did they tell you?
That wasn't the way it was.
And the answer to that is,
could it be anything?
It means every single thing about your
relationship past,
present and future has now been cast
into the realm of potential relevance.
And almost all the relevance is
negative.
And that's the descent into chaos.
So that's the best way to conceptualize
chaos is because what happens is that
your plan is what's narrows the world
for you and constrains that makes most
of it irrelevant.
The parts that aren't relevant,
positive,
and the negative elements,
relatively rare.
That's what the intact hierarchical plan
does.
If you blow the hierarchical plan,
then all your nice little subdivisions
are now irrelevant and every little
monster comes up to face you.
And that's the descent into the
underworld.
Right.
And people do not like that.
And no wonder the reason they don't like
that is because it places them in a
situation that's so complex that it
could easily exceed their resources,
you know?
And so for example,
one of the things that happens to
elderly people sometimes this isn't
precisely of betrayal,
is you know,
they've been with someone for 40 years
and the person dies while the
probability that the partner will die in
the following year is much elevated
compared to their normal mortality.
And part of that is they just,
it's not that they're grieving.
Exactly.
Although they are.
What's happened is that one of the
fundamental axioms of the structures
that they use to encapsulate the world
has been blown out and everything comes
crashing down.
And so sometimes people just don't have
the resources to make it through that
they're just done.
You know,
they don't know how to pick up the
pieces and start again.
You know?
And at some point,
maybe God only knows at some point,
maybe that's not what you do.
Like I don't know what you do after
you're married 75 years and your partner
dies.
I mean,
maybe you have a party if it's been an
absolutely dreadful marriage,
but,
but in all likelihood,
you know,
it's,
it's like a stroke that leaves you with
only half your body.
It's not clear that you can recover from
it.
So,
oh,
that's a good question.
But I would say what,
I don't think it's exactly from the
breaking of the framework.
I think what happens is that the
framework breaks and then the person is
cast into such a state of physiological
shock that the shark actually starts to
destroy them.
So like if I stress you enough for a
reasonable length of time,
you're going to blow out at your weakest
point.
And that's a nice way to think about the
genetics of pathology of
psychopathology.
It's like everybody has a weakest point.
You know?
It's like if you blow up a balloon
enough,
then it's going to blow out where it's
the weakest.
Well,
every one of you has a weak point.
You know,
some of you will have a threshold for
that weakness that's lower than others,
but generally if I push hard enough on
you,
you're going to,
something's going to happen.
You're going to,
you're going to get hypoglycemic and
then you're going to eat too much and
then you're going to become obese or
you're going to turn to alcohol because
it's a really useful antianxiety agent
for you.
Or you know,
you're going to develop some kind of
other stress related illness may be
diabetes or you know,
you're going to develop an anxiety
disorder post traumatic stress disorder,
or maybe if you have a family history
towards psychosis,
you're going to develop delusions and
paranoia.
It depends on,
it depends fundamentally on exactly
where,
where your most flawed in your,
in your psychophysiological makeup.
I don't think you can necessarily
predict how that's going to happen.
Although you can sometimes if somebody
has a loaded family history,
you know,
and even with with with uh,
illnesses like schizophrenia,
the standard models are always stress
dye thesis.
There's a preexisting vulnerability
which will not necessarily manifest
itself unless the person is put under
pressure.
You know,
and it's interesting to think we tend to
think about stress in some sense as a
psychological phenomenon,
but it's not really a psychological
phenomena.
Often even though it is related to the
way in which you construe the world,
the complexity of the world is what
stresses people that hasn't
psychological cause the world is
complex.
The psychological element is well are
your,
is your tool kit kit generally adequate
to deal with that complexity?
And some of that has to do with
subjective factors,
you know,
and some of it has to do with familial
and social factors.
So,
okay.
So I've considered construed a normally
as normal or revolutionary using Thomas
Kuhn's terms.
And a normal bit of a normally is one
that you can deal with without blowing
the framework within which you're
working and so on.
I hope everyone understands this.
I know I've gone over it a couple of
times,
but it's,
it's a very critical issue.
Does it make sense that the anomaly is
normal if it only disrupts subsidiary
elements of the plant?
Is,
is everyone clear about what that means?
Yes.
There's a spectrum because there's a
hierarchy and we'll,
we'll look at the hierarchy again,
but the idea is that the,
the,
the stress,
the stress of the normally is
proportionate to its position in the
hierarchy of plants.
The most stressful and normally blows
out your top level plan.
That's it.
That's,
that's a near death experience.
It means everything that you hold.
That would,
I would be what would happen if the
economy collapsed and your family was
killed in a car accident and your
partner left you on the same day.
It would be something like that.
It's like the bottom drops out of
absolutely everything,
you know?
And that does happen to people now and
then.
And we know what happens to people in
situations like that,
depending on their level of resiliency
because that,
that is another issue.
But one of the most common precipitants
of severe depression is unemployment.
You know when you might say,
well,
is that psychological?
It's like,
no.
I would say not really.
There's a psychological element in that
you might not be as well prepared for
about of an unemployment as you could
conceivably be.
But if I have someone in my,
as a client who's depressed and
unemployed,
what I try to do is treat the
unemployment,
not the depression,
because what the hell are they going to
do?
You know?
How can you not be depressed when you're
looking at a narrow way,
a world of narrowing opportunities
followed by losing your house and ending
up on the street.
It's like that's,
it's not exactly a psychological
problem.
Better limit.
How do you bring those levels?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean one of the thing is it's like,
it's like being able to move on your
feet.
So let's say,
well,
let's say you want to have your,
the first question is,
can you have a meaningful life,
right?
Because we're going to start from the
proposition that unvarnished life is
very dismal and dreadful,
right?
So if you're not prepared for it,
we'll just grind you up and that will be
very painful.
Okay?
So we're going to use that as a
baseline.
The baseline isn't that you're going to
be secure and happy.
The baseline is there isn't much of you.
You're very fragile and things will
grind you into nothing.
That's a Buddhist stance,
right?
Cause the Buddhists say first dictum of
Buddhism is life is suffering.
The first dictum isn't that life is
happy.
So the Buddhists basically say chaos is
the normative condition.
Okay,
so fine.
So you,
how do you do that?
How do you,
how do you deal with that?
It's not how you fight against it or
defend against it.
I don't think those are appropriate.
Conceptuals conceptualizations.
It's not positive illusions.
It's not defense mechanisms.
It's none of that.
Although you may also use that.
What it is is do you have an intimate
relationship that works?
Do you have a family that's that's net
work well together and strong?
Do you have some sort of interesting
occupation that regularizes your
schedule gives you something productive
to do on a longterm basis is stable and
productive,
right?
Do you have something that you find to
do or maybe more than one thing outside
of work,
right?
And Are you compromising your mental and
physical health by doing any things that
are particularly stupid?
And you know,
one of those,
I would like the top one of those I
would say is probably alcoholism.
So if,
if there's one thing you really want to
avoid that screws up your life,
it's drinking too much,
it is unbelievably dangerous.
So,
so the first thing we might say is,
well,
let's optimize those.
While the more you optimize those,
the more the more pillars there are in
your plant and they're only somewhat
correlated.
So maybe you can lose one or maybe you
can even lose too.
It's going to knock you down,
but it's not going to sink you.
You know?
And then you might also want to have
variants on those plans to some degree.
So like one of the things I mentioned
earlier is that it's always nice to have
an an alternative to your current job at
hand because it stops you from being
vulnerable.
It also stops you from being a slave or
a victim or maybe even stops you from
being a tyrant because you've got some
choice.
So you diversify your,
your hierarchy of plants essentially
just like you do.
You can think about it as stock market
investing in some sense it's a very
analogous idea.
You don't put all your eggs in the same
basket.
You diversify across multiple
portfolios.
So if one sector gets knocked out,
hopefully it doesn't knock you
completely out of the gate.
So,
so,
and that's partly what a guide you
through in the F in the future authoring
program too because it asks you to
consider what I think are the main six
dimensions of your life,
you know?
And so one of the things I do when a
client comes is I just do a rough walk
through of those dimensions.
It's like,
does anybody care if you're alive or
dead?
You know?
So if,
do you have any friends?
Do you have anybody that loves you?
Do you have an intimate relationship?
How are things going with your family?
Do you have a job?
Are you as educated as you are?
Intelligent?
Do you have any room for advancement in
the future?
Do you do anything interesting outside
of your job?
And if the answer to all those is no,
it's like you're not depressed,
my friend,
you just are screwed.
Really.
It's like if someone,
like someone comes to me and they're 40
and that's the issue,
especially if they're also drinking,
it's like Humpty dumpty has hit the
floor and no one is going to put the
pieces together because it's just,
it's too much.
It's too much people,
you know what I mean?
It takes a whole lifetime to put those
things together.
And that's not a sudden that might have
started as a psychological problem,
but by the time it's fully manifest in
your 40 that's not a psychological
problem.
It's just a complete catastrophe.
Okay.
Well I think sometimes antidepressants
help and the reason they help his,
cause they actually buffer the stress
response.
So you know you're being ground down the
world because essentially what you are
is you're,
you're,
you're not even in the dominance
hierarchy,
you're so low in the dominance hierarchy
or that you're not even in it.
Right?
You're an outcast fundamentally.
So maybe buffering the stress response
will help the person just not die from
that.
And then you start with one thing,
you know,
it's like you,
you lay out the potential areas for
improval improvement on the table and
you say,
well,
can we think of some small steps that
you might take in one or more of those
domains to start putting something solid
underneath your feet?
But it's what happens,
I think,
is that as you lose those pillars,
the way that problems manifest
themselves in your life becomes
networked.
And so you might make progress here,
but some other catastrophe that's
looming over here is going to knock you
down.
You know?
So yeah.
So there's that real happy,
happy.
What about people?
No,
it means that you're,
you're better protected against being
dreadfully miserable and swamp than you
would otherwise be.
So I would say you have to do those
things before you can even address the
issue of being happy.
Right?
Because if,
if you don't have,
if you haven't established yourself in
one or one of,
or two of those domains,
say there's some obvious things that you
could do to decrease the degree to which
your life is negative that you haven't
yet done.
So I would say you shouldn't even get to
the existential problem before you've
solved the practical problems.
And you may find that if you solve the
practical problems,
the existential problems would become
bearable.
Now,
not necessarily.
No.
Because I might say,
well there's another class of people and
I would say this is one of the
pathologies of being creative.
So if you're a high open person and you
have all those things,
that's not going to be enough.
You're going to have to pick another
domain where you're working on something
that's positive and somewhat
revolutionary because like the creative
impulse is for someone who's open.
We know it's a fundamental personality
dimension.
And I've watched,
I'd have clients who are very high in
openness and others who aren't.
And if the ones who are high in openness
aren't doing something creative,
then they're like dead sticks there.
They can't live properly.
So,
so you know that.
And I think those are the people,
for example,
who benefit particularly from depth
psychological approaches,
especially young Ian approaches.
I think that all of ewing's clients were
high in openness because I've watched my
clients,
I'll try union ideas out on them.
And if they're high in openness,
they worked like a charm.
It just fits right in with their psyche.
But if conservative people,
fundamentally conservative people low in
openness and high in conscientiousness,
they,
it just doesn't click because the union
approach is aesthetic and creative and,
and lots of people aren't either of
those things.
So there was another question.
Yes.
Yeah.
But they fight.
Especially if you're orderly,
you know,
cause conscientiousness is partly
orderliness and part of the openness.
Hitler was like that he was extremely
orderly and extremely high in openness.
And one of the ways he solved that
problem was,
which was quite interesting,
is that whenever there were art
exhibits,
exhibitions in Nazi Germany,
there were two types.
There was the approved Nazi art,
which was very structured and
conventional and uh,
you know,
bordered on the propaganda stick.
And there was forbidden art,
which was really chaotic.
And like often it was a,
the expressionists stuff for example,
which is really emotionally expressive
but chaotic.
And Heather would have both exhibitions
going on at the same time and one of
them would be forbidden,
then the other would be approved,
you know.
So,
but the problem with orderliness is that
you want everything to be in its
category.
And no wonder we've,
we've,
we've described why that is.
But if you're open,
you're always thinking,
well,
maybe there's a better way of putting
those things into a category.
And that's a,
that's a tough,
so orderly open.
People are always at odds with
themselves,
you know,
so
industrial and high in openness but like
not necessarily like I can see by the
[inaudible] but I also really old.
Yeah.
Well people like that are often
extremely successful.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
And it looks like industriousness is the
part of conscientiousness that predicts
longterm life success.
And orderliness is the part that
predicts conservative political
attitudes,
but low openness is also associated with
conservative political attitudes.
So okay.
So okay,
so,
so
the descent into the underworld,
that is basically what occurs.
It can occur at any level of your plant,
right.
From the macro levels to the micro
levels.
And what happens is that it's a descent
into chaos if the unexpected thing is
big enough to invalidate the framework
that you're using to deal with the world
at that moment.
Got It.
And then the degree to which you feel
negative emotion is proportionate to the
importance of that plan to the
organization of your perception and
action.
So you could think about it as you could
think about what you bring to bear on
the world.
It's almost like you can think about it
as how Google maps manages it.
You know how you can take Google maps
and the,
obviously it's a cybernetic
intelligence,
right?
The whole gps process because you say
I'm here and I'm going there,
and then it maps to rude out for you and
if you go off route,
it goes through a little period of chaos
and then it finds another route.
So it's really an intelligent system,
but you noticed that Google maps is
scalable,
so you can look at probably if you're
going from here to Mississauga,
using a map of Canada is the wrong map,
right?
You want to scale the thing down until
you hit the level of resolution that
both that best represents the situation
so that you can move to where you want
to go.
You can scale up and down in it,
and so finding out that the entire
country is being destroyed by nuclear
bombs is going to be a much bigger a
catastrophe in relationship to your
plan.
Then finding out that there's a few
obstacles in the street on your way to
Mississauga that haven't been marked on
the map.
And so,
so anyways,
you're going to be much more upset when
the entire superordinate,
the low resolution plans are disrupted.
Then when the high resolution plans are
disrupted,
and that's partly how your mind,
part of the problem we're trying to
solve here is how upset should you be
when something you don't want happens?
And the answer to that is that's
virtually impossible to compute.
But then the problem is you have to
compute it because if you don't,
you'll burn yourself out with stress and
worry.
And that's not psychological,
that'll just kill you because it's
actually a physic psychophysiological he
damaging process.
So you have to constrain it.
And so here's some of the ways that you
constrain it.
One,
you're born with a baseline level of
neuroticism.
So if you're higher in neuroticism,
you're gonna think that smaller things
are more catastrophic than someone who's
lower in neuroticism.
And you might say,
well,
who's right?
And the answer is it depends completely
on the situation.
And it's random.
It's fundamentally random.
And that's why there's a normal
distribution.
On average,
we would say that typical person is
matched to the typical environment,
but sometimes the terrified people are
going to be right.
And sometimes the people that you can't
bother,
no matter what you do are going to be
right.
Okay?
So that's one,
it's crapshoot.
The second is,
um,
where are you in a dominance hierarchy?
Because one of the things your brain is
trying to understand is how should you
regard yourself as an active and
competent organism when you're facing
problems that you can't compute.
And the answer to that is we're not
going to solve that.
We're going to distribute the problem
into the social network and we're going
to let everyone else solve it.
And so if you rise up in the dominance
hierarchy,
your brain reacts as if the dominance
hierarchy structure,
which is composed of many,
many brains has run its computations and
decided that you're pretty damn
competent.
And so the way your brain responds to
that is it cranks up your serotonin
production and decreases your
neuroticism.
And it's perfectly reasonable
computation because a,
if everybody says you're competent,
you're competent enough so that you're
going to get more rewarded for your
competence than other people are,
and that's going to make you more secure
in your job.
And it's gonna make you more desirable
and in demand among other people,
and that's going to give you access to
resources you wouldn't otherwise have.
So,
and then there's a,
there's a correlated element to that,
which is sort of your level of self
esteem,
although that's very much associated
with,
with neuroticism.
People with high self esteem generally
have low levels of,
of negative emotion.
It's not,
it's not clear that those are separable
phenomena.
All right.
What time is it?
Two 45 all right,
well let's stop for 10 minutes.
Okay.
And we'll,
yeah,
let's stop for 10 minutes.